all right let's let's let's talk about
the nightmare dystopia we are in because
we're in one you know we talk about
these flags being flown and we're like
well you know maybe it means this and
maybe they'll say this in the future i
give you this tweet from the read out
companies covering some or all travel
costs for abortions
we've got city yelp bumble levi's lyft
apple amazon starbucks zillow airbnb
paypal disney bank of america mastercard
tesla meta microsoft dix patagonia
jpmorgan match doordash netflix and
reddit
just some of the companies that are
covering the cost of abortion for their
female employees for one reason
maternity leave costs more money
welcome to the corporate nightmare
dystopia you've long been warned about
personally i never thought
paying for women to kill their children
because it's cheaper than paying for
maternity leave would become a left-wing
position but here we are i want to add
we here at timcast will not
be paying the costs for any of our
employees to travel to and seek out
abortions we do however offer unlimited
maternity and paternity leave because we
trust those who are going to have to
raise their family to spend as much time
as they need and then they can come back
when they see fit all they gotta do is
let us know and we will try and figure
out how to fill in because family comes
first and if every business worked that
way maternity leave paternity leave and
family comes first we have a very strong
robust healthy society but unfortunately
corporations today are saying look it's
gonna cost us four to five grand in
maternity leave and then you got
paternity to leave on top oh that's a
new thing and just give her the two
grand for the abortion and get rid of it
well also she's going to be working
fewer hours most likely she could
because she's going to be more focused
on being a mother taking care of her
child and oh my goodness it might even
be the case that she stops working all
together to be a stay-at-home mom and
then you have to find somebody else so
it's cynical it's evil they would
literally rather slaughter infants than
see any decline in their profits and of
course the left has a blind spot here
the left has a very obvious blind spot
here because they see abortion as
utility which allows them consequence
free sexual access to women's bodies
without any potential responsibility
being incurred as a result and so
they're completely willing to support
this horrific dystopian garbage
because if they didn't they would have
to come to terms with how twisted and
broken their world view is and they
would also
heavens forbid
have to live in a society where they
need to control their sexual origins
instead of doing whatever they want
whenever they want and that's ultimately
what this is all about
it's all about short-term pleasure i
gotta be honest like
it's not even about that because iuds
exist and condoms exist
it's like you don't have to control your
urges you just want to argue well that's
the thing one argument that they make is
well what if this fails and so there was
a there was an interesting analysis from
the brookings institute which came out
where they were looking uh at the
explosion in fatherlessness in the black
community and one argument they made is
it was actually the
legalization and increased legalization
of abortion prior to roe v wade and then
abortion being legalized nationally
after ov wade which led to the collapse
of the black family because it broke
down the expectations that you should be
with someone who you would have kids
with what greg what do you think about
the corporations oh i think
we have said this before we're living in
an era of work capitalism in which
companies pretend to care about social
justice to sell products to people who
pretend to hate capitalism and i think
that really you know just
there's money in it there's money in
virtue signaling there's money in
foe glamour and foe communism and we're
against the and i i just i i'm just
sometimes
frankly appalled at um
the hatred the the visceral hatred
towards this amazing country that i came
to 28 29 years ago and afforded me um
great opportunities and it's it's an am
i wish we could talk more about what we
love
as much as what we hate and
i think the the the wokification um of
america is just tragic in so many
respects it's just so amazing i wonder
how many these companies when they saw
the roe v weight decision they probably
went yeah baby because now we can
justify
not paying eternity to leave yep kaching
yeah how creepy is this it's like every
nightmare corporate
i just i just it's just i'm speechless
yeah it's disgusting i mean but this is
also part of what happens when you have
a society which restructures itself and
reorients itself away from being about
virtue and character development and
towards short-term gratification
ultimately that's what abortion is is
the ultimate example of saying all that
matters is convenience i don't care who
has to get hurt as long as i'm not
forced to take upon any responsibility i
got an idea for you seamus for a cartoon
it's a corporate psa from one of these
companies and they're like we here at
apple care deeply about our employees
that's why as an employee here if you
ever encounter an unwanted pregnancy we
will cover your cost to seek an abortion
and the woman goes what about maternity
leave no
well and so this is funny right the left
says we need abortion because we need to
guarantee a woman's right to choose but
then whenever they look at anything else
that happens in the corporate world
between an employer and their employee
they say this is a totally coercive
relationship people don't really have
the ability uh to choose new jobs so
this is i mean by their analysis this is
against women's choice because you
literally have employers economically
incentivizing women to kill their unborn
children amazing
another another idea for a bit would be
like a woman going into her supervisor
and being like i think i'm pregnant and
i may need maternity to leave and he
goes
have you considered aborting it and
she's like no i can't afford it we got
you covered um
the uh you guys followed that robert
reich is it reich or reich anyone anyone
know for sure whichever one's the bad
one yeah
and he tweeted out i guess
july
2021 let's get one thing straight
freedom doesn't mean you have the right
to recklessly endanger others by
refusing to get vaccinated i saw that
and then from like today or yesterday
tweets out i don't know who needs to
hear this but every every person should
have control over their own body so he
doesn't know who needs to hear it
because it's him a year ago
you don't have the right to refuse to
get vaccinated and then yesterday he
said you should have control over your
own body
i don't understand where the disconnect
is
well it's my body my choice until it
actually you know uh it's well it's like
you know there's a difference when it's
covered and when it's when it's the book
there isn't any logic you know it's not
hypocrisy
whatever benefits them is good period
yeah well yeah yeah i i i actually you
know i was flying here and i saw people
still wearing masks i don't think people
are afraid of coven anymore they're
afraid of of others knowing i think what
what covert revealed about themselves
and you know that whole that whole
situation that two years
of plus of covert to me was i mean i
called it right at the start the panic
damage not the pandemic um you know the
the
there was this this sense of
um you know taking away our rights
and if we let them take away our rights
during emergencies they're going to
continue to manufacture emergencies to
take away our rights and i you know to
me i'm i'm british i didn't grow up here
but i see this lack of people actually
getting it like
the freedom of speech is one another
thing i see in the uk they have hate
speech laws there are the police forces
are trolling the internet and arresting
knocking on people's doors and pulling
them in and
and charging them with crimes for things
they've said yeah i mean freedom of
expression like you know as long as
there's no enzymes if i say what you
want you know you don't have to agree um
but it's it's it is dystopia i mean you
called it it's this dystopia that people
just seemed many people don't see once
again and it's with and these are all
the companies that change their their
twitter avatars to rainbow flags
like they don't they don't care about
you
they're gutting the system so there was
uh in new york city and san francisco
there were stampedes at their pride
events
um i think in new york someone lit up
fireworks i'm not sure it might have
been both places and then people
stampeded out screaming thinking there
was a shooting
i was looking at these photos and these
videos of this stuff and i'm just like
at some point they i don't i don't know
if they ever were
about celebrating
love
it's you look at the videos you don't
think ever
i don't know i've ever not in my life
right not in my lifetime yeah my family
owned a cafe on the north side of
chicago and my i wasn't allowed to go
outside during pride
because it's debauchery it's nude people
doing things to each other and just like
things children
shouldn't see
and so my mom would be like hey pride is
this weekend don't go outside and we're
gonna you know just keep him in the back
don't let him see and then i remember i
had to go out one time and and i saw i
was a little kid nude women nude men
doing things inappropriate around
children people dancing around skipping
through the street naked there's viral
videos going around right now of of a
man wearing a bug's bunny mask totally
naked
dancing jumping through the street i saw
that and i'm 54 and i don't want to see
that there's a video of an old man with
a big gut and tidy white he's twerking
in front of like children
and it's like that's not about love
it's just not about love and being proud
of parents taking their kids out to see
just the same people who saluted uh
you know whichever corrupt ideology be
it the red salute or otherwise i i have
family members and friends that i i
couldn't believe it a few years ago
seeing them march the street do the red
salute
they're like oh it just means black
power and i'm like and the and the roman
salute meant white power you're doing an
identitarian salute to a fascist or
authoritarian regime like i don't care
what you think you're doing you're
you're in a death cult and you've lost
your mind there was a march in in i
think the uk a couple of weekends ago
maybe last weekend and uh and the chant
was ho chi minh che guevara stalin ochi
mensch and i'm thinking what are you
doing what are you doing
what are you you're walking through this
and i think they're just blindly
chanting catch phrases and you know
going back to communism and with no
understanding of history but then it's
no surprise given the educational system
given the fact that we're burning books
and we're knocking down statues and
we're not learning any lessons from
history or we're not relearning the
lessons from history that they taught us
and history tours it does it doesn't
matter what we know from history that's
the sad reality we watched them tear
down the statues we knew what would
happen when they did we learned the
lessons from 1984 they were renaming
streets that's one of the lessons and we
watched them do it in new york they
illegally painted black lives matter in
front of trump tower seizing taxpayer
dollars to do it and corrupt police
officers blindly and stupidly defended
it and arrested those who challenged it
the governments in these cities have
become overtly corrupt the institutions
are overtly corrupt we are watching it
happen and we know exactly what it means
in the turn of a century
when people are tearing down statues
and replacing them with idea with with
their own ideology and not being held
accountable the next steps are obvious
if we stay on a comparable track to the
1900s
and everyone knows it i know it sheamus
knows it you know it people have talked
about it ad nauseam the tearing down of
statues the renaming of streets 1984 is
here merrick garland rejecting the
ruling from the supreme court the doj
arresting republicans the front runner
in in michigan was arrested
we have a former trump senior doj
official jeffrey clark raided by the fbi
james o'keefe a news organization
admittedly according to the fbi raided
by the feds the federal government has
been weaponized and is going after
people who oppose their ideology they've
been tearing down statues and doing all
the corrupt things we expect and that's
it we know it's happening so what next
what is next i mean what do so people
listening to this original go well what
do i do what can i do
there's a possibility right now that um
in november the republicans win
and that's the big question if here's
what i fear
if the republicans win and then do
nothing
this this country has already collapsed
if the republicans win and then we see
investigations we see subpoenas
that could be pulling pulling us out of
the tailspin and correcting the
corruption of the biden administration
of joe biden himself the things his son
has done if those are investigated if
the summer of love riots are
investigated if the 529 insurrection is
investigated perhaps that could
lead to an uprighting and and pulling
this country back together do you think
there's an argument for the for the
convert the the the inverse of that yes
i'm just like let's just move forward
and not go back and forth between
impeach them impeachment no if the
republicans do nothing then the country
implodes because uh if you if
i've been doing a lot of reading about
the civil war
and one of the principal issues was that
the south felt the federal government
was not enforcing laws that harmed it
the north was getting to do whatever
they wanted and that's comparable to
what we're seeing now with antifa
killing you know anti-fun blm riding in
the summer of love and 30 plus people
being murdered dying david dorn being
shot in the chest kamala harris
fund-raised for these people joe biden's
staff donated to bail these people out
but outside of that you have trump
officials being raided by the feds you
have republicans like in nevada the
chairman having their phone records
seized the federal government has been
weaponized against their rival political
party if nothing happens you're going to
see this country get ripped apart
what's what i think is likely to happen
is
like texas it's already happening
actually missouri says they're they're a
sanctuary to federal gun laws new
hampshire just declared the same thing
california declared on immigration
they're ripping themselves apart from
the from the federal government saying
you have no authority here on these
issues anymore well it's not it's not
overt nullification they're saying we
don't recognize those laws and we will
not be party to any to assistance in
enforcement of them
that's step one
what happens now you've got all these
states saying we ban official travel
between these states for these things
they support the country is hyper
polarizing geographically that's a
precursor to outright statewide conflict
states interstate conflict
i think
if republicans get in and actually do
something
it will be tumultuous but maybe start
correcting the problems in this country
and restoring accountability if the
republicans do nothing confidence is
lost and without confidence people
ignore the system outright you see this
in
i saw this in sweden
a lot of people were saying the crime
was being committed by refugees it's not
true the crime was being committed by
the children of refugees people who were
born in sweden but were considered by
swedes to be immigrants
so what happens is you have these areas
like rinkaby in sweden
a bunch of somali refugees move into the
90s sweden says we don't care
they form an enclave they don't interact
with the outside government
today their children who have never been
a part of the system will throw bricks
at cops because they don't see the cops
as having any real authority and the
cops know it
that leads to total destabilization if
you get to the point in the united
states where people view the government
as illegitimate like aoc said the
supreme court's illegitimate several
other you know federal level politicians
have said this merrick garland the
attorney general rejected the supreme
court ruling said we're going to resist
this and we're going to ensure these
things stay
the country at the highest level
officially is being ripped apart
if that continues you will have people
in texas saying we don't recognize the
federal government at all and they'll
completely ignore it already starting to
happen texas legally allows for
suppressors manufactured in texas to be
used in texas without going through the
nfa stamping process
which is a federal law it's all it's
already begun
it can change if confidence is restored
there's a possibility that if
republicans get in and start doing
things the left reacts so violently that
it's inevitable
i don't know for sure
i can only tell you
if you read history read read the
history of the spanish civil war read
the history of the the bolsheviks and
and russia you look at what's happening
now and i don't see how you can imagine
this results in a peaceful process i
just don't see it thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you